foreign
is a family business built out of
passion for live sport fill out the
fundamentals of sport for competition
the Legacy for greatness for putting a
smile on people's face
now that's key for us is not just to
deliver for athletes but to deliver Live
Events and content that the viewer
watching on platform or live in the
arena can leave with a smile on their
face and realize the true beauty of
sport
Eddie Hearn is the chairman of matchroom
sport which is a British event promotion
company it was founded by Eddie's dad
Barry in 1982 and they cover all sorts
of sports like snooker darts nine ball
and eventually boxing which Eddie
revitalized over the years when I moved
to the company I took the golfers that I
was representing on the PGA tour and
European tour from another company to
Metro to set up a golf division
boxing was a tiny tiny part of the
business our biggest business probably
was the emergence of online poker and we
were in charge of putting together all
the major Productions globally for
televised poker and I took over the
poker department and we grew that to a
substantial size to the point where
virtually every televised poker event
that you would see was a matter in
production and it made us a lot of money
we like characters you know we like
creating content we like creating
formats we like creating compelling TV
if by Sports even better but I looked at
poker and I looked at the characters and
the personalities of the players and
just believed that we could create
something fun we could create great
content great narrative great storylines
I think one of the reasons we've been so
successful in sport is through building
those characters those personalities and
those storylines they're all great sport
events have great narrative and that's
something we've been very successful
with and in poker the characters were
some of the best we've ever worked with
Eddie's impact has primarily come in
boxing which matrim had boxing
operations but not to the level that
Eddie has transformed it to Barry Hearn
is Eddie's dad an accountant by trade he
found a matchroom in 1982 and he told me
that was because he was bored he had
been buying up snooker halls around
England and that had become a pretty
viable business for him and uh he had
become close friends and worked with a
former world champion Steve Davis and
they had seen real interest in Sport and
from there they found they could just
promote those events and one thing led
to another one sport led to another and
matchroom eventually became the company
that you see today
when Eddie joined matchroom in 2000 The
Firm was pulling in roughly 1 million in
profit on 10 million of Revenue I was
playing a poker event the World Series
of Poker and I bumped into Ollie
Harrison who was the Olympic gold
medalist heavyweight tried to kind of
guide his own career and lost and
kind of wasn't a bit of a dead end in
his career and we just started talking
and he said you know could you promote
me so I don't work in boxing he said I
know but I know matchroom do a few shows
here and there
so I said look you know I could take you
into prize fighter which was this
tournament we were doing and then you
could fight for the European title and
if you win that you could fight David
Haye for the world heavyweight title
and he sort of said really can you do
that I was like yeah 100 and left that
conversation phoned my dad who wasn't an
Audley Harrison fan and he just said
look you're on your own you know he went
out he won prize fighter he won the
European title and then he fought David
Hayford the world heavyweight title we
did that fight it was a disaster it was
a complete mismatch Audi Harrison didn't
fire a punch we made some money already
made Seven figures and I said that's me
done in boxing all of a sudden all the
fires started calling me would you
represent me
so all of a sudden next we've got Carl
frotch who is the world champion Darren
Barker Kell Brook three of the best
fighters in the UK wanting to sign with
me I was all of a sudden in front of all
the cameras at the press conferences
selling this fighter I was
you know mid-20s or late 20s and didn't
really know what I was doing but I was a
breath of fresh air in boxing you know I
mean I've seen everything that you could
ever see in boxing
and I never felt that I would
necessarily become a boxing promoter
but matram had a great reputation in
boxing but British boxing was dead
no one was trying you know there was our
broadcaster which was Sky Sports had
four promoters which was matchroom Frank
Warren Ricky Hatton and Frank Maloney no
one liked each other though I was really
trying you know the the industry and the
Old Guard didn't like me but all of a
sudden this young kid's coming in whose
father's a Hall of Fame promoter saying
he's going to rip up the script to box
him and then I went to our broadcast I
said you need to get rid of everybody
and just sign an exclusive deal with me
and they said we don't do that we've got
our four promoters that say it's never
going to work none of them have any
ambition and none of them like each
other you need to get rid of them and
give me the exclusive deal I said I'm
going to show you what I'm going to do
and I went out from local Leisure
centers started building big fights in
big Arenas seven eight nine thousand
creating big numbers and big audiences
on sky for boxing and when the deal came
up six or eight months later they got
rid of everybody and gave me the
exclusive deal
from there Eddie did things like
embracing social media putting boxing in
stadiums more often you know embracing
the celebrity and women's fighting
spaces and ultimately eventually tried
to crack the US market and brought
fights to the Middle East we don't
sit here and profess to be
Albert Einstein but we know that you
will never outwork us and
it keeps it simple you know if things
start getting a little bit tough
he just says make sure you go to sleep
an hour later and get up an hour earlier
and work harder
you know it was a very unforgiving
development that I had you know I had a
nice house
but it was just drilled into me from day
one work work work work work
you know
don't give in don't let them get you
down just out working and outperform
them and when you have consistency and
when you have ability and when you have
a drive that is unbeatable you can't
lose it's just a case of playing the
game over time Forbes estimates that in
fiscal year 2023 matchroom posted
revenue of 365 million at a net profit
of 60 million across the entire business
the zone is a streaming service that has
strived to be the Netflix of sports
they've brought up all sorts of
different sports rights around the globe
and their partnership with Eddie and
matchroom was a means to enter the U.S
boxing Market in 2018 Eddie and Matt's
room to a degree shocked the boxing
World by signing an estimated one
billion dollar deal with the Zone The
Zone has had a bit of a rocky course but
has more found its footing of late and
they they operate globally they have all
sorts of different sports rights around
the world but this deal was supposed to
be Eddie's entrance into the U.S market
this was going to bring you know the
successful things he had done with
matchroom in the UK overseas into
America
when you're putting on a fight there's a
lot more risk than let's say when the
NFL team plays a game and that's because
if you're the New York Jets even if
nobody watches the game you're still
going to get your share of the
meteorites money that that comes down
from the league whereas in boxing the
event has to make money or exceed that
to reap the rewards now promotions and
broadcasters have gotten pretty good at
working with other companies to project
out how many pay-per-views they can
actually sell and they can get it to a
pretty good margin so that they can
prepare for the worst and hope for the
best and that makes it so it's hard to
kind of completely Miss on a fight but
there's a risk there and they're taking
a risk the US is one of the richest
loudest noisiest Sports markets on the
planet there are so many different
things competing for eyeballs whether
it's you know professional football
basketball or whatnot and boxing already
has its own established presence here so
for him to say he was going to come in
and take it over you know essentially it
was a bold claim you know we've been
with Skye for decades in boxing and they
were a fantastic broadcaster but our
vision had changed from a British
promoter to a global Powerhouse we
wanted to replicate the success of the
UFC and the WWE to become a global
promoter we wanted to go out and do
individual broadcast deals in new
territories great government interest
and start taking our brand globally for
boxing The Zone shared that passion and
that Vision they had a platform globally
that could be used and would invest in
different markets that were key to our
expansion so UK we did a big U.S deal
all of a sudden we're doing six shows
here in Mexico Italy Spain Australia the
Middle East
and the only way we could move forward
with that global vision was to do a deal
with the Zone in the UK space and
obviously financially it was a huge deal
for us that really changed the look of
our business as well so it was a
difficult decision because we took a
risk if you like in terms of the
exposure
follow the growth and we believe in
streaming we believe that streaming is
the future of live sports
um and I believe the Ott platforms are
also the future of live sports as well I
just believe that the way the new
generation
digest content is now completely
different you know we know that people
do not sit at home in front of their big
screen like they used to they want to
watch content on the go they want to
watch it by their handset I'm a strong
believer that that's the future of
broadcast you only have to see the Next
Generation
when it comes to fight fans the
sentiment can be mixed but when it comes
to other promoters especially here it
seems that there's no love loss for
etihana matchroom and part of that stems
from The Zone deal and entering the U.S
market you know he's someone who has
never been afraid to play the villain
and to be in front of the camera and to
piss people off
so naturally people aren't going to like
you when you do that I mean a lot
everybody likes to be a hero you know
I'll receive a huge amount of criticism
and a lot of it's my own doing you know
I'm very outspoken as you've seen today
do 50 or 60 interviews a day I'm going
to say something that's going to piss
somebody off and the way the internet
works the way headlines work and click
bait works of all these different
Outlets you're going to upset people
when I went into America the strategy
was to upset people quickly
to build a profile to create noise
create interest I'd like to be a hero in
terms of the time and the sacrifices
I've made for the sport of boxing I love
boxing It's My Life
um and I've given a lot of my life to
boxing and I make a lot of sacrifices
for boxing them for the business but at
the same time I have no problem being a
villain and every Market that I go into
they try and get me out ASAP so when I
came into the UK there's a very famous
photo of all the current British
promoters who all hated each other and
they all put their hand in the middle in
this picture and they said a united
front for British boxing
and then there was Eddie Hood
and that was it and that's the same in
America now Oscar De La Hoya Bob arum Al
Hayman Lindell Levy they're all talking
with with voice to say this say this
keep keep the pressure on he won't he
won't be able to handle it because that
was the thing in the UK it was like
we're just gonna break him and they
never did and now in the US they're
trying to do exactly the same thing keep
the pressure on force him out turn the
fans against him but they don't realize
one how good I am but also the power I
have across my platform they can't work
like me
so I'll do as many interviews it takes
and I'll communicate with the fans all
the time and that's the most powerful
tool we have the ability to talk to the
audience
baronetti have a really good
relationship Barry said to me that him
and his son are very close and like best
friends but they are almost unhealthily
competitive they will still go back and
forth about you know how different
divisions in the company are having
financial success
either very famous father certainly
within the area that I grew up with and
I loved it you know I couldn't stop
telling people that Barry home was my
dad and probably for my early years
everyone knews me is Barry's son
or Barry's boy you know my dad was quite
flamboyant
um came from nothing really made money
was quite extravagant and enjoyed
himself it was away a lot but always had
the time when he was at home to
play with me play sports with me and
that was really what my childhood was
built on sport we played every sport we
played to win competition was ferocious
and that's what I was that's how I was
brought up winning is everything you
know it was never about taking part you
know if I went out and lost three new at
a game of football he'd say what are you
doing come on you know not a well done
you know you did well there son sport
was a foundation for us to learn about
the important aspects of life
and that transferred into business
when I left uh College I wrote to every
major sports event athlete management
sponsorship Marketing consultancy in
London you know Advantage IMG I wanted
to cut my cloth in the industry without
just working for matram and I went to
one sponsorship and marketing sports
agency called BDS and I sat down with
them and they were reading my CV
and they said gosh are you any relation
to Barry Hunt
I suggest my dad and they sort of said
what are you doing here it was about the
time when Jerry Maguire came out really
I always saw myself as a budding sports
agent and that's the field that I wanted
to to go down and that's really where I
cut my cloth before moving into the the
business
you know my dad is as I said earlier
he's money mad
you know every day he's analyzing again
I mean my dad's a chart accountant by
trade
so every day he's analyzing accounts
he's looking at bottom lines he's
looking at profit and losses from each
individual event and he drives me
berserk
because we're working with you know
inboxing particularly
sometimes there's more of an emotional
attachment you could be investing in a
fighter to bring a major world
championship fight to their home City
but the show loses money but you've got
that emotional investment for the
fighter so he'll remove himself from
there but
um
yeah I think that my father has always
said
no shareholders
no float we do things our way
and
I convinced him to change his mind on
that probably three years ago as our
growth continued to to move rapidly and
he's changed his perception so probably
that probably that the opportunities we
have for a rapid Global growth come
potentially in different ways and and he
leads those conversations today
Eddie wants to take match from public
and he does think that could happen
sooner rather than later which is one of
the reasons why he has been talking
about a private Equity investment in the
company but also he does see a future
Beyond boxing one of the sports that
matchroom promotes darts they
effectively own the sport they just
completed a lengthy acquisition
acquiring the professional darts
Corporation and Eddie is extremely
bullish on the growth of that we want to
make sure that our Sports our business
our brand name is recognizable in every
key market across all our Sports
um
it's a natural move for us to lead to an
IPO I think it's only a matter of time I
think we're so unique in what we do in
terms of ownership of sports and being
able to mold those sports
but we must continue to have fun
because that really is his Mantra you
know we love what we do and we love to
have fun what we do we believe we've
built an incredible management within
the business that must be free to
continue to spread their wings but we
also realize the opportunity that
presents itself in this economic world
of of growth for the business globally
and to do that in a rapid way then
these conversations that are ongoing
that will lead to an IPO is a natural
progression